welcome to today's webinar gmp cleanroom
routine
environmental monitoring and 21 cfr part
11
data integrity i am jennifer woods of
law roots and i will be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by beckman culture life sciences
to learn more visit beckman.com we
encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
i would like to now present today's
speaker tony harrison
senior marketing manager beckman culture
life sciences
tony you may now begin your presentation
fantastic thank you very much for our
introduction so
hello and welcome everyone to this short
webinar today
on clean room environmental monitoring
and 21 cfr part 11 data integrity
as per the introduction my name is tony
harrison and i am a senior manager for
beckmann coulter
i was also the uk expert to the iso
working group responsible for writing
the 2015 edition of the iso
standard for clean rooms iso 144
6 sorry 146 44-1.
before we begin i wanted to share this
quote with you because i thought it was
very uh on point
sometimes clean routine environmental
monitoring programs can seem very
burdensome and with the sheer volume of
manual sampling leading to a high volume
of data to be managed
this sheer volume of data can be
confusing and lead to lack of clarity
and data integrity errors
so in today's short webinar i will cover
the gmp requirements for clean room
monitoring
and for classification and explain the
difference between the two
i will also outline why routine
monitoring presents such a challenge to
data integrity
and finally i'll give some brief
highlights onto the new clarity software
for routine monitoring
and how it can automate these programs
and help reduce
data errors
so first of all let's take a look at the
gmps and the world health organization
guidance for clean rooms and also
take a look at the iso standard for
clean rooms iso 146 44-1
2015.
now of course we're all very painfully
aware of the current global
covid pandemic and it's injectable drugs
like the vaccines that we're all
receiving now
that are in fact the biggest risk for
contamination for humans
and this is because of course as we've
probably seen
over the last few weeks and months they
are injected directly into the human
body
and by doing so they bypass our defenses
and any microbial contamination they may
contain
would cause an infection possibly blood
poisoning
and possibly death
our most vulnerable are the weak and
immuno compromised and again we've heard
about that with the covert pandemic
and this includes such patients as
premature birth babies
um if they're born too early they have a
very weak immune system
and they can't feed from the mother so
we have to feed them of course using
intravenous drip bags
which they which contain all the food
that they need in the form of total
parental
nutrition now the issue is if any
contamination gets into those
parental nutrition bags then it will
cause almost certain death to these very
very weak and immunocompromised patients
so here's a not not too
old example of what happens when clean
contamination control goes wrong
in 2012 in north america a manufacturing
clean room of a small
compounding company became contaminated
with a spore forming fungus
and this found its way into the drug
product
now this particular drug product they
were making was a very strong painkiller
killer delivered to patients via direct
injection into their spinal cord
17 000 vials were contaminated
sadly 64 people died when they were
injected
and they died from meningitis which is a
swelling of the
membranes of the brain as the trunk
fungus invaded their nervous system
and again sadly 750 more people were
infected
before they they did the drug recall and
there is no cure
now the biggest challenge in clean rooms
is the contamination risk that the
people
working in the cleaning rooms present to
the product the average human being has
around 100
000 billion bacteria on and inside their
body
now we shed over 30 000 skin cells per
hour in fact we shed and replace our
entire skin every month and each of
these skin cells is smaller than the
human eye can see
and carries many microbes which could
contaminate the pharmaceutical product
in fact during the course of a year we
shed 3.6 kilos of skin cells
so now let's take a look at the the usa
gmp document the cgmp
document and compare it to the european
and the world health organization gmp
documents
now they define the acceptable levels of
airborne particles
in clean rooms for sterile drug
manufacturing
and both the gmp and the cgmp document
call up the iso standard 146-44-1
for the methodology for clean room
classification so
just for classification
so let's take a look at the gmp
regulations
this is the current table for air
particle contamination levels in the
european
gmp mx1 and also the guide for sterile
manufacturing from the world health
organization
now you can see there are four grades of
clean room
defined from the very cleanest which is
the grade a through to the dirtiest
grade d you can see that the european
gmp
calls for two particle sizes to be
measured uh 0.5 microns
and 5 microns and this is the same the
world over it's the same in the world
health organization documents and the
only difference is in the north american
cgmp document
which only calls for 0.5 micron
particles being measured
and reported reported
now all particle counts are reported in
particle counts per
cubic meter and this itself can present
a potential
area of error for our customer for our
users because
in order to reduce the amount of time
taken in environmental progress programs
each day
the sample taken at each location by the
air particle counter
is typically just one minute sample now
with a particle counter that samples at
a flow rate of one cubic foot
per minute it means that the sample
taken during that minute
is just one cubic foot of air now there
are approximately 35.2
cubic feet in one cubic meter of air so
the user must multiply that one minute
sample by 35.2
to get the counts per meter now
it's true to say that most particle
counters can be programmed to
automatically make this calculation for
the user
but it is another configuration step
that the user has to remember to do
to ensure results are reported correctly
now as i mentioned people are the
biggest source of contamination in the
cleaning room environment
so workers in clean rooms have to pass
through
several different clean rooms to enter
the production site
suite sorry each area is separated by an
airlock to minimize the flow of air from
the dirty outer rooms
into the clean production area
excuse me particle counters have to be
sanitized as they pass from one grade of
clean room to another
to avoid contamination being carried
through and this is typically done by
spraying them with an
industry alcohol spray called ipa
the dirtiest room is the great d and
staff are required to change
in this room out of their outdoor
clothes and into clean room clothes
they then pass through into the great
sea preparation area
where equipment to be used in production
is prepared and assembled
and finally they're quite often required
again to change as they
pass through into grade c preparation
into the grade
b production area generally the grade a
production filling area is protected by
a barrier system
either an isolator or a restricted
access barrier or labs
and that prevents the workers from
entering
and if this is the case then the
environment around that grade a
area can be grade c but if there's no
physical barrier for the filling zone
then the background to that grade a must
be
grade a
now i mentioned that the north american
cgmp document differs to the european
and the world health
organization guidance in that it only
mentions one particle size
the 0.5 micron particle however
drug manufacturers based in north
america wanting to sell their products
outside of
north america and into the rest of the
world they'll have to count particles of
both 0.5 and 5 microns
as they must be in compliance with the
standards used in the country to which
they want to
export
now vaccine manufacturing plants are a
rather unique subset of biopharma
production
in that the production of a vaccine is
quite often done by cultivating high
concentrations of disease causing
pathogen
and this is done in bioreactors that are
optimized to support cell growth
unfortunately these bio reactors are
also optimal to support microbial growth
so this gives the manufacturer
additional challenges over and above
the manufacture of other injectable drug
products
extra care must be taken to avoid
bacteria from the production staff
from getting into the bioreactors and at
the same time
great care must be taken to prevent
cross-contamination
between the production lines
hence vaccine production lines and the
staff and equipment working on them are
usually kept
separated from each production line to
prevent this cross-contamination
now these challenges so well known that
the welt organ
world health organization have these
dedicated guidance specifically
for environmental monitoring of clean
rooms in vaccine manufacturing
facilities
now as i mentioned earlier both the
european gmp and the north american cjmp
documents tell the reader
to refer to the class classification
procedures
laid down in the iso standard 1464-1
now the iso standard is not a gmp
document
and it's designed to give guidance
rather than mandate
but the fact that it's referenced by the
gmp effectively gives it the same status
as a gmp document now for those
manufacturers regulated by gmp
the iso has a wide range of clean room
classes from one to nine
and it covers particle sizes from 0.1
micron up to 5 microns in size
and then of course the number of
particles per cubic meter for each class
is defined in the table
now the idea is that the user must
decide what particle sizes they are
interested in and how clean the clean
room must be
to carry out their process and then they
choose a subset of the clean room class
and particle size from the iso table
gmp has decided uh that the political
size of interest
are 0.5 and 5 microns
and you see from the grade b at rest
from the european gmp
that the number of particles matching
match iso class 5
so those numbers are directly lifted
from the iso
but an important thing to note here is
that the 2015
version of the iso standard no longer
specifies
the number of particles of 5 microns for
iso class 5.
however users who are regulated and
complying with the gmp
rules they have to measure the 5 microns
too
so the fact is not mentioned in the iso
standard
does not mean that gmp cleanroom users
no longer have to measure the five
micron particle
they do because it's mentioned in gmp
so let's take a look now the difference
between
clean room classification and routine
monitoring
of course portable air particle counters
are used for both applications in the
gmp
clean room classification and of course
routine
environmental monitoring but they are
very different things
the clean room classification process is
very well defined in the iso standard
1464
whereas it is the responsibility of the
cleanroom user
to define the routine environmental
monitoring program specific
to their own production process the
product they are manufacturing
and their clean room design the user has
to take ownership
of their environmental monitoring
program and must design the program
based on a risk assessment
of the specific process products they're
making and the clean room
now this as i mentioned classification
is very well defined in the iso standard
and it focuses actually on the clean
room rather than the product
safety so make sure the clean room
itself is performing to the target
cleanliness
class it's very well defined as i'd say
and it's usually carried out every six
or twelve months
now iso standard 14644
tells the user how to calculate the
number of sample locations
required for the room it depends on the
size of the clean room basically
and then it tells the user to lay these
sampling locations
out on an evenly distributed grid
pattern across the room
there's no requirement in the iso
standard to take samples where the
product
may be at risk of airborne contamination
so in the example on the screen here and
this is just an example just to explain
uh following the iso standard means that
there are no samples taken in
areas where potentially the product may
be at risk for example
the d scrambler table the filling zone
itself and the stoppering zone
or indeed the capping station
now for clean room environmental
monitoring there are actually no
hard and fast rules here there's no
document defining exactly how many
sample locations and where you should
sample
the user must make a risk assessment of
where the product may be exposed in
their process
to airborne contamination and set
sampling locations at these points for
their routine environmental monitoring
programs so if we go back to the example
i was showing a moment ago
for the clean room which is being
classified
you can see that the classification asks
for them to be laid out in
a grid pattern but
um the theoretical example we're using
here they've taken a look at their
manufacturing process and they've
decided on those locations
where the products may be at risk from
airborne contamination
and they've laid out their sampling
program appropriately for routine
monitoring
and you'll notice these sample locations
highlighted by the yellow
numbers there they're very different
locations to those used for
classification so
they're very different classification
looks at the room
monitoring looks at hazard to your
process very different things so
you need to be aware of that
so let's take a look at the root cause
as to why
routine environmental environmental
monitoring can
provide challenge in regards to
maintaining
data integrity
routine environmental monitoring can be
typically a very manual process
involving the collection of thousands of
samples
each month using portable particle
counters
typically there are manual sop steps
which must be followed
in a routine environmental monitoring
program
first of course the technician has to
make sure that they're using the correct
version of the environmental monitoring
sop which is typically a paper-based
document
and then they have to follow the
sampling map in the sop
and go to each sample location defined
they then have to manually type the
location name into the air particle
counter
via the on-screen keyboard and next they
have to configure the counter
to sample for the correct amount of time
and for the correct number of samples
according to the sop
for each location next they print the
sample results out from the counter
and handwrite comments onto the printout
and sign it with their name
and at the end of each day they
photocopy all the paper printouts
and then they manually type the results
into from every piece of paper into an
electronic record
and finally the electronic record itself
is reviewed by the supervisor
to ensure that all the samples have been
taken
and the data in the electronic record
actually matches the paper printouts
so as you can see this is a very manual
process
and with thousands of samples per month
thousands of pieces of paper
and manual data transcriptions the
opportunity for human error to creep in
and impact the integrity of that data
very high
now in that 2018 guidance the fda
introduced
the acronym alcoa saying that a good
electronic record should be attributable
to the person who's taking the sample
they're suggesting it shouldn't be
handwritten because sometimes hand
writing can be misinterpreted or
illegible in fact
they're suggesting these records should
be made contemporaneously which means at
the same time
the measurement is made rather than
created at a later time
and pay for printouts and it should be
the original record
and the data which contains should be of
course accurate
which is where human error can come in
so let's take a look now at the clarity
software
and how it can help make routine
environment
environmental monitoring less error
prone
clarity software actually runs inside
the particle counter itself
allowing you to improve the accuracy
because your own
sop sampling map can be uploaded onto
the counter screen
so this creates an interactive version
on stream
and clarity software includes
electronic records straight from the
counter itself
and they can be exported via wi-fi or
wired
ethernet as standard automatically
and the data is exported in a pdf a
secure pdf file
and excel which is exactly what the fda
recommends
they suggest pdf in their 21cfr part 11
guidance it uses microsoft
active directory for credentials for
username and password so
you use the same credentials for the
particle counter
as you would use for your company
computer when you log on in the morning
and it also uses a secure file transfer
using something called ldap so on the
left hand side here you can see a
typical electronic record created by the
particle counter
now you'll notice it says the sop
version on on the screen here that's
because
the sops are controlled in the counter
itself
i'll go into that in a minute but the
version control that's
available on the counter is controlled
by the manager or
administrator you can attach a barcode
reader to the particle counter to
capture
active air or settle plate ids from
barcodes
uh straight into the electronic record
so you not only have
uh the um air particle counts
but you also have the settle plate
barcodes and the active airplay barcodes
tied into that electronic record so it
pulls everything
together for you
so as i mentioned the clarity software
runs inside the counter there's no
external software
and hopefully this allows the user to
improve accuracy
because your own sop now resides in the
particle counter there's no paper
records
it's an interactive on-screen map and as
the technician moves to each location on
the map
they simply tap the location and this
automatically configures the counter
exactly as you would according to your
sop
accuracy is improved because all our
technician has to do then
is tap run sample there's no
configuration or manual data entry or
labels of the sample location
nothing like that just simply tap the
screen and press run sample
the accuracy is further improved as the
sop version control
is now done inside the counter itself
so administrators can log on remotely
just using a web browser
and configure an sop and then release it
for use using their electronic
signature
so the clarity software creates the
final record inside the counter itself
there's no need you can still have paper
printouts but there's no need for paper
printouts or manual data transcription
the record contains the sop name and
version number
the user's electronic signature the
production id batch if you want that
the location name for the sample which
as i said is pre-programmed the
technician doesn't have to enter that
date and time of course
uh configuration of the counter of
course the particle
sampling results including the sample
volume that was collected
and if there are any alert or action
alarms they are included in the
electronic record
and the user has an opportunity to enter
comments
maybe for instance to explain what why
the alarms went off
um and and why it's not an issue but
they all go into the electronic record
and the final step of course in the
process is the review and approve
now the clarity allows the administrator
or the supervisor to
log into the particle counter remotely
over the ethernet network simply using a
web browser
there's no specialist software required
and the clarity workflow
inside the counter allows allows the
supervisor to review
the day sampling and then once they're
happy with it they
export the whole day's sampling as an
electronic record
straight from the counter to their
secure server wherever that might be on
their network
they can do that by usb or wide ethernet
or wi-fi
and uh security this is guaranteed by
using their having to use their
microsoft active directory credentials
to log on to the counter
in the first place
the counter also contains an integrated
audit trail
which contains the user id of the
person's running the instrument
log on the success and failures are
those
sample completion changing group
commissions
calibration information changes to an
sop
if the data is exported then that's
recorded in the audit log as well
and any changes to the instrumentation
configuration
so that concludes my short presentation
today
so if we may let's see if there are any
questions
in the chat
thank you tony for your informative
presentations
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
thank you for your presentation there
are many particle counters available
on the market please can you summarize
the key difference
with your met one thirty four hundred
plus and how it helps improve data
integrity
what makes the 3400 plus different
thank you for your question well there
are four clear differences
um the primary one being the map on the
screen
it's an interactive map but it removes
the need to manually configure the
counter at each sampling location
and so this avoids errors in the data
itself
so the counter also produces the
electronic record contemporaneously as
the
sample is taken and this avoids data
errors that can occur when you manually
transcribing
from paper into an electronic record the
third point really
is that the accuracy of the data is
confirmed by the built-in review and
approved workflow so the supervisor
can remotely review the data make sure
it's all been taken that day
just using a web browser and then they
can apply their electronic signature to
a data record and that can be exported
and
finally the process of capturing the
environmental monitoring samples
can be reviewed to make sure there's no
errors using the built-in
audit trail
thank you tony our next question is
you show a remote review and approve
feature for the met one
what software is required to access the
counter remotely and how do you
guarantee
security so actually in fact you don't
need any software to access the counter
remotely
as long as the counter itself is
connected to your company
network via the built-in wi-fi or wired
ethernet
you can control the sop versions and
review
and approve the day's environmental
monitoring data from your office
remotely
just simply using a web browser such as
chrome
now security is assured as the user
when they first log on to the counter
they have to use their microsoft active
directory controlled username
and password which is the same they
would use to log on to their
company computer and they have to enter
that into the web browser interface in
order to
browse the counter remotely so it's very
secure
great thank you tony our last question
today
i can see that the microsoft active
directory can help
records be attributable but why is it
better than usernames and passwords
created in the counter itself
that's a good question you can choose
not to use the microsoft active
directory feature if you wish
and create local usernames and passwords
in the counter itself but
the idea behind using active directory
is that a
it enforces the users to use the same
level of complexity
for their username and passwords as is
defined by their corporate id
and b it stops the use of generic
passwords that everybody uses
on the counters because they don't want
to remember yet another password
so as you can imagine in a fleet of
particle counters it won't take long
before the password you use on the
counter
gets out of sync and you end up needing
different passwords for different
partial counters
so what i've seen is that some teams
often use the same generic password and
of course this remove uh
downgrades security and also removes the
traceability
so using active directory avoids this as
you only have to remember the same
password
that you use to log on to your company
computer each day
thank you again tony harrison for your
time today
and for your important research we would
also like to thank labruz and our
sponsor beckman colter life sciences for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye